during covert 19 and you being an
enthusiast of weed would you share a
joint with anybody during these times
absolutely not
i don't know if anyone's sharing a joint
again anytime soon
so baba bowie you know baba bowie he's
describing to me went over a friend's
house you know they were
socially distancing blah blah blah blah
blah i guess they were drinking and he
was even wearing a mask he was wearing a
mask doing all the things
and he he smoked a joint he shared a
joint with a guy and i go are you out of
your [ __ ] mind he goes it was the
stupidest thing i ever did
okay i will give a little context to
this if i could was it a joint
it was a pipe okay we were drunk
did you leave the lighter over the
mouthpiece room
we wiped the pipe down with an alcohol
rub that's all
okay okay okay don't encourage this
mitigating your risk if nothing else i
still don't
i would i don't know if i'd encourage it
necessarily
until there's a vaccine i am not sharing
joints with anybody
and i'm i'm lacing all my joints with
the covid vaccine as soon as it is
available
now i'm going to confess something right
now and this is such a weird thought
and you know how much i love
interviewing you and being with you and
i i i really do
i'll know if i'm doing an engaging
interview for seth rogen
if he doesn't pick up that joint and
smoke it
you've done it he could hardly drink his
coffee you didn't give him room for
anything
which and that has been one of the great
joys of all this is i've finally been
able to smoke weed
while i do press which is all i've ever
wanted
but i but but you were too engaging
today you got me